let's go to vanessa in utah vanessa
how's it going good thank you so much
for taking my call
you betcha how can we help um so
i am a full-time student i work
full-time
and i just had a baby and now i'm
basically a full-time
mom all the time now and that kind of
let
a fire under my butt on getting on top
of my finances i've never really
budgeted before
me and my husband decided that we want
better for our family in the future and
long-lasting wealth like you guys were
talking about earlier
um so i just had a conversation with my
parents the other day that they are
being very gracious and they're helping
me pay for student loans
um i have about 33 000 in student loans
i have a year and a half left
by the time i'm done um in my well
when i start my career i'll be making 80
000 a year
and they're giving me 400 a month to go
towards whatever like we need
but it's like intended for helping with
schooling that they had promised
before and weren't able to help in prior
years
um and i have a car loan of about
twelve hundred dollars um and so i'm
wondering
if it would be smarter to put that money
and pay off the car
faster or do i put that
towards the student loans
i'm gonna take that money and add it all
towards your debt snowball so
what's the lowest thing that you have
right now in debt
um it would be probably my credit card
okay which i just pay off every month
and then
um the thing is i'm like not very
financially smart i guess in
educated and so i don't know like if my
student loans they like i can see
they're broken up by
each specific loan but i know that when
you graduate it's all kind of just one
big box fund so i'm not really sure
how that works um so then there's like
you know thirty five hundred dollar loan
and twenty five hundred dollar loan
and this and that and then add that adds
up that's up yeah so vanessa one of the
things that we teach here is the debt
snowballs so number one
uh i'm not gonna you know hammer this
down your throat today but you already
know what i'm about to say you gotta cut
up the credit card i get the idea of
paying off every single month but
you know what i teach there so that's
that after that i want you to line up
all your debt from smallest to largest
so i want you to break
down your student loans uh a loan b loan
c loan d loan and attack it that way so
make all your minimum payments
you know on each one and then the extra
that you have left over from the four
hundred dollars that your mom are giving
you or from your income
put that towards the smallest loan work
it the exact same way so i'm not saying
hey just put one towards the lump sum of
a loan no
knock out one loan a loan b loan c loan
d loan and then go from there but how
much is your car worth
um i'm not really sure i bought it at 22
000. okay all right how much um when did
you buy it
uh 2017. 2017. so you should be right
around like 15
16 and probably what kind of car is it
it's a crv
crv okay cool so it should be worth
right around 13 in
um and so i would definitely attack that
i mean once you get a job
i would definitely definitely attack
that your parents are taking good care
of you so that's a good thing
okay and vanessa thank you so much
vanessa thank you full-time student
full-time employee now you're a mom
you grew a human yeah all this in 2020
i don't ever want you to say the words
i'm not that smart ever again
okay okay thank you for you someone who
is is willing to grind and work hard and
be a person of
of high responsibility and character
integrity
this is this is an easy thing for you to
figure out okay
okay thank you so much put your head to
it put your mind to it put your heart to
it you're gonna be out of debt in no
time you're gonna be an extraordinary
mom that's
that's awesome yeah that's awesome i
mean that's really that's a lot i mean
full-time
full-time student full-time employee and
a full-time mom
she got three full-time jobs i tell you
what and that
being a full-time mom is like five
full-time jobs she's got nine full-time
she's got 17 full-time jobs right now
absolutely
especially to a newborn baby but there's
nothing that will get your fire going
like looking at another human being that
is totally helpless and dependent on you
saying
what's my legacy going to be mom what's
my legacy going to be dad
what's it going to look like right i
look forward to that day yeah yeah